Hallo, schönen guten Tag.
Ich bin hier als ersten Tätich und heute kümmere ich um Sie.
Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, gerne.
Danke schön. Ich bräuchte erst Ihren persönlichen Daten. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Peter Schmidt.
Peter Schmidt mit DT oder?
Doppeltee.
Mit Doppeltee? Ja.
Herr Schmidt, wie alt sind Sie?
Wie bitte?
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 35 Jahre alt.
35? Wann sind Sie gerne aufgeboren?
Am 4. April 1989.
1989.
Wie sind Sie? Wie schwer und wie groß Sie sind?
Ich bin 1,75 m groß und 82 kg schwer.
82 kg leicht.
Erzählen Sie mal.
Herr Schmidt, weshalb sind Sie hierher gekommen?
Ich habe Rückenschmerzen in meiner Ländengürbelsäule.
Seit gestern haben die Schmerzen zugenommen.
Seit gestern zieht der Schmerz in meinen rechten Beinen.
Ich habe einen Ziehen in den Schmerzen in meinen rechten Beinen.
Die Schmerzen haben zugenommen.
Wie kann die Schmerzen?
Ziehen die Schmerzen?
Können wir über einen Ausstrahlen spielen?
Schmerzen strahlen?
Ja, kann man auch sagen.
Ziehen die Schmerzen ein.
Bis in meinen großen Zehen.
Bis in den großen Zehen.
Sind die Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam angefangen?
Gibt es einen Auslöser?
Gibt es einen Unfall?
Nein, ein Unfall gibt es nicht.
Ein Auslöser fällt mir auch nicht ein.
Also nichts Besonderes.
Haben Sie etwas Schweres angehoben?
Nein, nicht, dass ich wusste, nein.
Nein, ganz plötzlich?
Nicht ganz plötzlich, sondern seit einer Woche tut das Reh so ein bisschen.
Und seit gestern tut es halt mehr weh.
Also es ist nicht so, dass ich sagen kann,
dass es ein bestimmter Zeitpunkt ist, dass es passiert ist.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Stellen Sie vor einen Skala.
Und stellen Sie sich einen Skala vor.
Einst bedeutet leichte Schmerzen.
Und sehen bedeutet unerträgliche Schmerzen.
Wo würden Sie Ihre Schmerzen einordnen?
Ich würde sagen bei acht.
Oh, das ist aber sehr stark Schmerzen.
Ja, deswegen bin ich hier.
Ich verstehe.
Haben Sie gegen Ihre Schmerzen etwas eingenommen?
Medikamente? Ja, ich habe zu Hause Prophäen.
Wie viel Minigram?
600 Milligramm.
Ja, so ungefähr 2-3 Mal am Tag nehme ich die ein.
Ich glaube 3 Mal am Tag.
2-3 Mal am Tag.
Ja, also seit gestern 3 Mal am Tag.
Und hilft das, Ihre Schmerzen zu lindern?
Ja, ein bisschen.
Eine leichte Linderung habe ich dabei.
Wir können auch etwas, ein Schmerzmittel Ihnen anbieten.
Aber können Sie bitte bis Ende unseres Geschäbwerks?
Ja.
Wir können aufhalten.
Ja, das geht.
Ja, das wäre besser.
Anstunsten kann es die richtige Diagnose verfalschen.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Aber Sie können sich auf die Untersuchungsliege legen,
wenn es Ihnen besser geht.
Nein, das ist okay so.
Vielen Dank.
Ich versuche schnell das Geschäbwerks zu Ende bringen.
Ja.
Haben Sie, gibt es ein Taubplatzgefühl oder Kritten an der betroffenen Seite?
Ja, also ich habe so ein komisches Taubplatzgefühl
an meiner Außenseite von meinem Oberschenkel.
Das ist so ein bisschen pelzig Taub.
Am Oberschenkel.
Das heißt nicht Arm, sondern an meiner Außenseite
meines Oberschenkels.
Aber im rechten Oberschenkel Außenseite.
Rechten Oberschenkel, Außenseite.
Aber Sie, pelzige Gefühle.
Ja, so komisches Gefühl, pelzig Taubesgefühl.
Das ist, die Empfindung ist ein bisschen anders,
ein bisschen weniger als auf der linken Seite.
Ich verstehe.
Können Sie Ihre Zeche oder Ihren Fuß bewegen?
Schmerzlos bewegen?
Ja, also ich kann es bewegen.
Allerdings habe ich so ein bisschen Kraftverlust,
wenn ich meinen Fuß hochhebe.
Also wenn ich laufe, habe ich ein bisschen Problem beim Laufen.
Weil ich laufe, man hat Probleme.
Schmerzhaft, oder?
Nein, nicht schmerzhaft, sondern ich habe Probleme,
weil ich den Fuß nicht so ganz hochhebe.
Aha, okay.
Sie können Ihr Fuß nicht hochheben, ja?
Ich kann den, aber nicht kräftig.
Ja, es gibt eine Bewegungseinschränkung in dieser Seite.
Ja, an dieser Seite, okay.
Kraftverlust, würde ich eher sagen, ja.
Aha, okay.
Ich kann, wenn ich passig meinen Fuß hin und her bewegen,
kann ich bewegen, aber ich habe nicht die Kraft,
um es zu bewegen.
Ich verstehe.
Ja, das ist eine wichtige Information für uns.
Und, haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Haben Sie noch andere Schmerzen?
Meistere Schmerzen, nee.
Nur im Nettenbibbesollert, der in den Beinen aufstrahlt.
Ja, gibt es etwas, das Ihre Schmerzen lindern?
Wenn ich mich hinlege und meine Beine hochhabe,
sozusagen, ein bisschen, gibt es da eine Linderung?
Okay, vielen Dank.
Jetzt komme ich, jetzt muss ich einige allgemeine Fragen stellen,
diese können in Ihrer Beschwerden in Verbindung stehen.
Haben Sie Fieber, Herr Schmid?
Fieber, nein, habe ich nicht.
Nein, leiden Sie unter vermehrtes Schwitzen oder Nachtschweiße?
Nein.
Nein? Okay.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Nein.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Auch nicht.
Auch nicht, gut.
Haben Sie Atemnot?
Auch nicht.
Gut.
Und sieht es denn mit dem Wasserlassen aus?
Haben Sie damit Probleme?
Nee.
Okay, ist Stuhlgang in Ordnung?
Was waren Sie mit in Ordnung?
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Nee.
Vielleicht Verstopfung oder manchmal Durchfall?
Nein.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Stuhlgewahnheiten ist regelmäßig gut.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit, Herr Schmid?
Mein Appetit ist gut, also nichts Besonderes, normal.
Ja gut, habe ich Sie in der letzten Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, nicht wieder ab und auf zu genommen.
Ich bin mit Vergleich gewichtig.
Ja, sehr gut.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Haben Sie Probleme, Schwierigkeiten einzuschlafen oder durchzuschlafen?
Gestern hatte ich halt, bin ich mehrfach aufgewacht, aber ich kann eigentlich schlafen.
Wegen den Schmerzen habe ich gestern ein bisschen Probleme gehabt.
Gestern Nacht.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen zu Ihrer aktuellen Beschwerden?
Nee.
Legen Sie mal, ja, gibt es etwas, das Sie mir sagen?
Ja, gut.
Und jetzt möchte ich zu Ihrer Vorgeschichte übergehen.
Gibt es Vorerkrankungen bei Ihnen zum Beispiel, Zuckerkrankheit,
Bluthoffdruck, eine ehrliche oder geistliche Krankheit?
Nee, nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Nein, gar nicht, sehr gut.
Wurde Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, ich wurde am Blindamm operiert.
Wann war das?
Damals war ich 15 Jahre alt.
War die Operation komplikationslos?
Damals hat man mir Antibiotika gegeben und da habe ich allergisch reagiert.
Was für eine Antibiotika ist das? Antibiotikum ist das?
Soweit ich das weiß, heißt es Penicillin.
Penicillin.
Wie umsetzt sich die Allergie? Erinnern Sie sich daran?
Ja, ich hatte Atemnot. Also ich konnte nicht richtig atmen.
Okay, also, haben Sie ein Allergiepass?
Ja, da steht auch drin, dass ich Penicillin-Agelle allergisch bin.
Ja, das ist wichtig. Reagieren Sie noch auf etwas allergisch?
Nee.
Nein, gut.
War Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Letzte Zeit im Ausland? Nein.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bedarfliherweise Medikamente ein?
Ich nehme keine regelmäßige Medikamente ein.
Bis auf die letzte Zeit wegen Ibuprofen, wegen den Schmerzen.
Ja, das habe ich schon notiert.
Ja, gut, raucht sich Herr Schmidt?
Ja, so. Ja, ich rauche.
Wie viel und wie häufig rauchen Sie?
Ich rauche, man kann sagen, halbe Packung am Tag.
Ich rauche schon.
Seit wann?
Seit 15 Jahren.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Alkohol, ja.
Welche Alkoholart trinken Sie?
Wie häufig?
Am Wochenende trinke ich ein Bier, wenn ich Fußball spiele.
Wie auch am Wochenende, gelegentlich.
Gelegentlich oder bei Geburtstagfeiern.
Ja, das ist in Ordnung.
Eine reine Routine Frage, die ich aus medizinischen Gründen stellen muss,
hatten Sie Erfahrungen mit den Drogen?
Oh, nee, ich weiß noch nicht mal, wie das geschrieben wird.
Okay, prima.
Jetzt komme ich zu Ihrer Familiengeschichte.
Ist Ihre Eltern gesund
oder gibt es eine chronische Erkrankung in Ihrer Familie?
Was meinen Sie mit chronischer Erkrankung?
Noch nicht, zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck.
Überhefte Cholesterinwerte oder Zuckerkrankheit.
Also meine Eltern, meine Eltern,
die nehmen irgendein Medikament wegen Bluthochdruck ein, beide.
Und die Mutter hat irgendein Problem mit der Schildrüse.
Dann nimmt sie Medikamente ein.
Okay, eine Unterfunktion?
Ja, Unterfunktion, genau.
Okay, haben Sie Geschwester?
Ja, ich habe eine Schwester.
Ist sie gesund?
Ja.
Gut. Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Mahler.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein.
Mit wem wohnen Sie zusammen?
Nein, ich wohn alleine.
Machen Sie, regen Sie sich Sport?
oder laufen Sie?
Ich mache Daumen Sport.
Daumen Sport?
Ja.
Was weiß ich nicht, was bedeutet das?
Nichts machen.
Paulensen, ja?
Nein, Daumen Sport halt.
Ja, okay. Vielen Dank für die ausführliche Informationen.
Ja, jetzt sind wir am Ende unseres Gesprächs gekommen.
Und überlegen Sie mal, gibt es noch etwas,
das Sie hinzufügen können?
Nein, nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Okay, haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, wie geht es denn weiter?
Was wird gemacht? Was habe ich denn vorhin?
Ja, erst werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Dann einige Test, eine Bewegung möchte ich durchführen.
Einige Test, das Untersuchungen, inschuldige.
Ich werde die Beweglichkeit Ihren Beinen und Füßen beurteilen.
Dann brauchen wir einen Röntgen oder einen MRT.
Wenn alle Betunde vorliegen, dann nehmen wir...
Was ist denn ein Röntgen oder MRT?
MRT Magnet Resonance Pormography.
Sie werden in einer Röhre liegen.
Dann werden wir Schnittbilder von Ihren Körper,
Ihren inneren Organe, erhalten.
Ist es gefährlich in einer Röhre?
Nein, es ist nicht gefährlich.
Falls Sie Angst haben, können wir Ihnen ein Berichtungsmittel anbieten.
Das ist ein Magnetfeld.
Es ist eigentlich nicht schädlich.
Eigentlich?
Es ist komplikationlos.
Das andere, was Sie gesagt haben, was ist das?
Das ist Röntgenaufnahme.
Das ist eine Röntgenstrahlung mit Hilferabstrahlung.
Darum ist es gefährlich?
Das ist nur eine geringe Menge von Strahlen.
Es kommt infrage, deswegen ist es nicht gefährlich.
Nur einmalige ist es nicht gefährlich.
Im Umfeld können wir solche Strahlen bekommen.
Im natürlichen Umfeld?
Zum Beispiel wenn sich Haare mit Trocken oder elektronischen Geräte zu Hause.
Es gibt auch Strahlung-Exposition.
Im Röntgenaufnahme ist es sehr gering und theoretisch nicht gesundheitsschädlich.
Das liefert sehr wichtige Informationen zu uns.
Deswegen müssen wir das durchführen.
Sie müssen das durchführen.
Oder würden Sie gerne durchführen?
Ja, genau.
Jetzt nehmen Sie bitte Platz im Untersuchungsraum.
Wir sehen uns in weniger Minuten wieder.
Danke Frau Doktor.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Bitte schön.
Hat der Patient Probleme, sein Urin zu kontrollieren oder sein Stuhlgang zu kontrollieren?
Nein.
Ich habe die Frage gestellt.
Haben Sie Probleme bei Wasserlassen oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Stuhlgang ist fest, aber nicht gefragt, ob es eine Kontrollfüllung ist.
Ich frage, ob es ein Problem ist, dass ich mein Urin kontrollieren kann.
Ich frage, ob Sie Probleme haben.
Nein.
Danke schön.
Ich denke, keine Fragen haben unsere Kollegen.
Deswegen können wir erst als Geist beantragen.
von ihrer Seite aus. Von meiner Seite, ich weiß nicht. Ich versuche.
Bitte schön. Ja, schönen guten Tag. Ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen, falls Sie für mich kurz Zeit haben.
Ja, bitte. Ja, der Patient heißt Peter Schmitz. Er ist 35 Jahre alt, 1,75 m groß und wiege zur Seite 82 kg.
Er kam heute zu uns wegen seit einer Woche bestichender Zunehmender.
Zunehmender und seit gestern stark zunehmender starker Schmerzen, starker Lumbargie.
Er berichtete, dass die Schmerzen in den rechten Beinen bis zu groten Zäh ausstrahlen würden.
Sie haben gesagt, Lumbargie. Wie heißt es dann, wenn Rückenschmerzen mit Ausstrahlung in den Beinen da sind?
Lumbago. Lumboischelgie.
Das wusste ich nicht.
Also Lumbargie oder Lumbago ist Rückenschmerz und Lumboischelgie ist Rückenschmerz, also Lumbarleschmerzen mit Ausstrahlung in den Beinen.
Lumboischelgie im Verlauf des Ischas, sozusagen, merf es Ischadikus.
Lumboschelgie.
Rechts in dem Falle.
Lumbar ist chialgie.
Lumboschelgie.
Ischelgie kommt von Ischas, nefus ischadikus.
Algie Schmerz.
Okay. Der Schmerzcharakter beschrieb Herr Schmidt als sichend.
Die Schmerzintervität wurde mit acht von zehn bewertet.
Gegen seine Schmerzen habe Herr Schmidt Ibuprofen eingenommen.
Seit einer Woche nehme er sich zwei, drei Mal täglich, um seine Schmerzen zu lindern.
Okay.
Diese aber nur eine leichte Linderung der Schmerzen gebracht.
Ja, außer der Erwehnungswert ist zu den Parästhesien in den rechten lateralen Oberschenkel.
Er klagt über einen Kraftverlust.
Und ja.
Kraftverlust? Wie würden Sie das?
Astheni.
Ne, eine Fußheberparäse.
Paräse.
Fußheberparäse.
Aus dem Klakt er über eine Fußheberparäse.
Paräse.
Er erzählte, dass die Zähinlegen, die wir hier haben,
als er erzählte, dass sich hinlegen würden, die Schmerzen lindern.
Und die Beine hochlagen würden die Schmerzen...
Hinlegen und die Beine hochlagen.
Er erzählte, dass sich hinlegen und Beine hochlagen würden die Schmerzen lindern.
Vegetative Anamnese ist unauffällig.
Der Patient habe keine Vorerkrankungen.
Er wurde in einem Alltag von 15 Jahren appendektomiert.
Nach dem OP wurde bei ihm Antibiotika, Penicillin, verabreicht.
Darauf wurde der Patient allergisch reagiert.
Patient?
Er wurde der Patient allergisch reagiert.
Er wurde allergisch reagiert.
Medikamentanamnese, Ibuprofen, Einnahme, unauffällig.
Herr Schmidt ist raucher, mit ca. 3,5 Päck.
Er trinkt gelegen Alkohol, Drogenkonsum, wurde verneint.
Anamnestisch fand er sich beim Vater altrierlich, Hypertonie
und bei der Mutter eine Hypotreose.
Er habe eine Schwester, die gesund sei.
Herr Schmidt ist Malerkomberuf, ledig und wohne alleine.
Okay.
Ein Gesicht der anamnestischen Angaben
vernutete ich in diesem Fall einen länden Wirbelsäure-Biskussprolabs.
Differenzial diagnostisch, um einen Zipinalkanal der Nose und
eine unspezifische Kreuzmärschung vor einem Mialgie.
Okay.
Ja.
Wie würden Sie vorgehen, damit Sie Ihre Verdachtdiagnose erhärten
oder ausschließen?
Ja, bei der körpferliche Untersuchung
habe ich eine Schwertung, eine neurologische Untersuchung
und einige Nervendehnungszeichen überprüfen.
Okay.
Ja.
Und ich werde Kraft, die Muskeln und Sensibilität
und Durchpollutung überprüfen.
Es gibt natürlich einige Zeichen, die auf die
Lesion-Lokation hinweisen können.
Okay.
An welche, was würden Sie spezifisch da denken?
Ja, Lasekzeichen, zum Beispiel.
Lasek, Braggart zeichnen.
Wir machen das immer zusammen.
Ja.
Anhand der Beschwerden, was der Patient hat,
können Sie sich vorstellen, weil Sie sagen,
das könnte ein Bandscheinvorfall sein.
Welche Etage das sein könnte?
Ja, es gibt ein, es gibt eine Biskale,
die wird gegenseitig werden.
Aus der Schmerz, ist die Herzkardiikut betroffen?
Ja, oder die Bootschen von der nervischen
Schardiikus, okay.
114, 114, 111.
Aber welche, ja, wie bitte?
114.
114, fast richtig.
114, 111, 115.
Sorry, 115, 111, genau.
Ja, der Nerv hat ja einen Namen und dieser Nerv würde L5 sein. Wahrscheinlich durch L45 oder L5S1 kommt drauf an, wie der Prolaps sich ereignet.
Aber der Nerv L5 ist bestimmt, da ist bestimmt ein Wurzelkompensionskompressionssyndrom, L5. Warum sage ich L5?
Weil die Schmerzaufstrahlung oder die Problematik in diesem Dermatom, also lateraler Oberschenkel ist Dermatom L5.
Fußheberpalize gehört auch zum Nerven. Zurückzügehörgeschwindigkeit ist auch L5 sozusagen.
Was würden Sie nach dieser ausführlichen körperlichen Untersuchung machen? Wie geht es dann weiter, nachdem Sie untersucht haben?
Dann eine MRT-Untersuchung ist notwendig.
Okay, das würden Sie einfach empfehlen.
Ja.
Und würden Sie Röntgen durchschüllen oder nicht?
Ich würde vielleicht eine Fraktur auszuschließen.
Wie? Noch mal?
Vielheit eine Fraktur auszuschließen, kann ich einen Röntgen anrunden.
Genau.
Gut.
An weichem Teil können wir nur mithilfe einer MRT losteilen.
Okay.
Gibt es da eine Alternative, wenn man kein MRT hat, das man durchschüllen kann?
Schalke.
Ultrachalke, vielleicht?
Nein, nein, das ist zu tief.
Enge, nein.
Nein.
Eine bildgebende Verfahren, meine ich.
Eine Alternative zu MRT, wenn man, wenn der, wenn man keinen hat oder wenn es...
Auf CT natürlich.
Genau. Man kann es auch durch CT durchschüllen lassen, als Alternative also.
Wie Sie wollen, sagten, ist MRT das Wichtige, aber wenn es gar nicht geht, kann man auch ein CT bekommen.
MRT kriegt man nicht sehr schnell einen Termin meistens, da muss man ein bisschen warten.
CT kann man schnell durchschüllen lassen, ist der Vorteil.
Nachteil ist Röntgenstrahlen durch CT.
Ja, natürlich.
Okay, aber eine Alternative wäre das.
Okay.
Was empfehlen Sie dem Patienten?
Was soll er jetzt machen?
Wie geht es jetzt voran?
Sie haben jetzt einen MRT machen können.
Und MRT sehen wir, dass tatsächlich ein Bandscheinvorfall L4-5 entstanden ist.
Rechts, der auch einen Wurzelkompressionssyndrom ausführt.
Wie geht es voran? Was würden Sie machen?
Für pferliche Schonung ist wichtig als Erstes.
Nicht etwas Schweres anheben.
Würden Sie eine konservative Master oder eine operative Master haben?
Physiotherapie wäre sehr hilfreich.
Wir müssen vielleicht nicht direkt eine Entscheidung für Operationen treffen.
Erst eine konservative Therapie sollte durchgeführt werden.
Und davon soll natürlich eine Schmerztherapie begleiten.
Okay.
Wann würde man eine OP-Entscheidung durchführen?
Wann würde man eine OP empfehlen?
OP, ja.
Chronische Nerven schaden vielleicht.
Chronisch weiß man nicht.
Er ist jetzt da und hat eine Fusheberparise.
Wenn ein Patient eine Parise hat, sollte man eigentlich operieren.
Es kann zu einem bleibenden Schaden sein, wenn er eine Fusheberparise behält.
Dann wäre es zu spät, wenn wir in einem halben Jahr oder ein Monat oder drei Wochen eine OP durchführen.
Weil Nerven können sich manchmal nicht regenerieren.
Oder sehr langsam regenerieren.
Deswegen würde man bei einer Fusheberparise, also das heißt, wenn ein Muskelausfall da ist, eine Parise da ist,
Muskelebung sozusagen, würde man eine OP empfehlen sozusagen.
Aber in Klammern ist ja auch nicht unbedingt Parise.
Man nennt es Kraftgrade.
Wir wissen nicht, weil wir noch nicht darüber gesprochen haben, wie schwer diese Parise ist.
Wenn es ein Kraftgrad von 4-5° da ist, kann man vielleicht ein bisschen abwarten, gucken und mit Kortisonen, Injektionen und so weiter versuchen, das zu therapieren.
Aber wenn ein Kraftgrad mehr als 4-5°, so zum Beispiel 3-5° wäre oder weniger, dann würde man empfehlen, dass man zeitnah operieren sollte.
Also es hängt davon ab, die OP nicht nur das Parise ist, sondern die Art und Weise, wie die Parise ist.
Bei fortbestimmter Parise macht man OP, bei nicht fortbestimmter Parise kann man Aufklärung der Patientin und sagen, wir können versuchen, das mit konservativen Maßnahmen zu retten sozusagen.
Also kann solche Komplikationen spontan auftreten?
Ich sprach spontan, der sagt, wenn die Bandschein vorfall, seit gestern hat er das Problem, weil es ist spontan sozusagen.
Kein Auslöser, also muss er Möbel packen, das kann auch spontan entstehen.
Wer fasziert ist noch jung?
Es gibt Leute, die sind 18 Jahre alt und haben einen Bandscheinvorfall, ohne dass sie schwere Sachen machen.
Es ist nicht ein Gesetz, dass er alt sein muss, um das spontanen Bandscheinvorfall zu sein.
Wir wissen nicht, ob der Generation, der wie besöle durch Skoliose hat, wie sein Vorlieben ist, was er im letzten Jahr vielleicht sehr schwer gearbeitet hat.
Nur jetzt in sechs Wochen hat er nicht schwer gearbeitet.
Die letzte Zeit, eine Woche, haben wir gesprochen, vor einer Woche oder zehn Tage hat er nichts gemacht, aber vielleicht hat er drei Monate davor schwer gearbeitet.
Oder der ist gestürzt, kann auch dramatisch bedingt sein, dass da ein vorschadendes Stand ist, aber erst jetzt kommen die Beschwerden.
Kann alles möglich sein, also muss jetzt nicht ein akutes Situation auftreten. Das kann plötzlich kommen.
Also wichtig ist, dass sagen die Leitlinien, dass wenn jemand eine Paräse hat, OP, keine Paräse, keine OP.
Einfache Regel.
Und keine Paräse, also vorhin hat jemand auch in die Gruppe geschrieben, zum Beispiel Stuhl-Incontinents oder Urin-Incontinents, wenn sie neurologische letztendlich Ausfälle haben.
Es geht nicht um Paräse, sondern es ist auch, wenn ein Beckenbodenmuskulatur nicht funktioniert oder irgendwas.
Wenn jemand ein Problem hat, schnell wie möglich MRT und wenn es nachgewiesen ist, sollte man eine OP empfehlen.
Dann hat er nur einen Bleibnudel schaden, wir Ärzte können ja nur empfehlen, dringend empfehlen, aber wenn der Patient sagt, ich will dich operieren, ich bin glücklich, wenn ich Stuhl-Incontinent bin, dann ist er glücklich.
Es ist jetzt extrem gesagt. Also wir können nur empfehlen, wollte ich damit sagen.
Oder wir können dringend empfehlen, das zu operieren.
Wir müssen nur aufklären.
Okay.
Vorhin, gleich noch das zu kompliziert, sagen wir mal, der hat einen Kraftgrad 4,5-Til oder 4 Plus, also noch knapp 4,5-Til, fast 5,5-Til, ein bisschen Schwäche, ganz leicht.
Dann würde man konservativ empfehlen erstmal.
Was würden Sie empfehlen? Konservativ, was würde man machen?
Physiotherapie.
Einmal, genau.
Analgesie natürlich.
Analgesie alleine?
Ja, Cortison, Injektion, vielleicht.
Also anti-inflammatorisch auch therapieren, nicht nur analgetisch, sondern an analgetisch und anti-inflammatorisch, in Form von NSAR oder Steroide, Cortison.
Ja.
Gaben würde man empfehlen.
Okay, fast noch, also Analgesie mit anti-inflammatorischen Therapie, Physiotherapie, fast noch, das können wir noch mal haben.
Auch empfehlen, Rücken schonend sich zu verhalten.
Zum Beispiel.
Wie können Sie wiederholen?
Rücken schonende Tätigkeiten durchschüren.
Das heißt, eine Rückenschule, also man kann auch ein Rezept ausstellen, dass der Physiotherapeut eine Rückenschule, also beibringt, wie man etwas hochhebt,
dass er vorsichtig ist, sozusagen.
Rückenschule ist der physiotherapeutische Begriff.
Rückenschonende Tätigkeit ist der generelle Begriff.
Rückenschonende Tätigkeiten durchschüren.
Keine Letruhe, ja?
Keine Letruhe.
Ich würde sagen, es ist alles erlaubt, was nicht wir tun.
Oder es ist, Zeit ist auszwischte.
Wenn er sagt, ich habe Schmerzlinderung durchliegen, dann halt öfters liegen.
Aber wenn er nur eine Bettbohr hat, ist es auch schwierig, sozusagen.
Wenn er längere Zeit das Problem hat, dann kriegt er Muskelschwund, Musselatrophie sozusagen.
Okay.
Und wenn die Maßnahmen nicht helfen, kann man immer noch eine Operation empfehlen.
Ja, natürlich.
Okay.
Dankeschön.
Können wir sagen, so ein Satz, bei Versagen der konservativen Therapien, konservative Behandlung,
müssen wir eventuell eine chirurgische Therapie nachdenken oder überlegen?
Wir müssen, sondern sollten.
Sollten nicht.
Wir müssen, wenn nicht.
Sondern wir sollten, wir empfehlen dringend, zu diskutieren, nachdenken.
Man kann auch sagen, sollte man eine Operation denken oder diskutieren.
Also nicht dings, muss, ist falsch.
Der Patient entscheidet immer noch, was er mit seinen Grapper macht.
Deswegen.
Sollten wir.
Sollten wir, genau.